[music playing]
September 19, 1961
has the first really
dramatic and well publicized
case of alien abduction.
Betty and Barnie were
driving through the White
Mountain area of New Hampshire.
RICHARD DOLAN: It
was late at night.
Betty sees this unusual light
that seems to be maneuvering.
This light stopped in midair
directly in front of us.
The car motor stalled.
And at that point, I realized
that they undoubtedly
planned to take us on board.
And then, the next thing
is that they're 35 miles down
the road, and they
have no idea how they
got that far down the road.
It turns out they were
missing two hours.
BARNEY HILL: My wife decided,
well, we should notify someone.
And we thought of
notifying the military base
located in this area.
JACQUES VALLEE: A radar had
detected something unidentified
and had reported it through
channels inside the Air Force.
They had tracked an
identified craft at 2:14 AM,
just about the time we
estimate that the UFO left.
They developed a
series of nightmares.
And, as a result of that,
ufologists told them,
you should be regressed
hypnotically to try
to see if you remember more.
The doctor who did the
hypnosis was Dr. Simon.
He was an expert.
And he played the tapes for us.
They are terrifying.
BENJAMIN SIMON: All right.
BARNEY HILL: Looks like a
big pancake with windows.
JACQUES VALLEE: Something very
traumatic had happened to him.
The Betty and Barney Hill
case interested my father a lot.
And he did take part in
the hypnotic interview.
RICHARD DOLAN: This
case did get a lot
of behind the scenes
attention from some very
interesting scientists.
They wanted to
know what happened
to Betty and Barney Hill.
[music playing]